you went to the dinner with the queen I
was with the queen and the president
just last week yes for an American I
kept trying to figure out why why am I
here what how did this why did this did
I win a ticket
[Music]
lady lady you run this place
there we are we were often there's my
white tie and Tails
that is not a rental by the way
they had a they had a powder blue one I
said let me let me wrote the traditional
black
it's kind of like on a first name basis
what did you meet her oh yes oh yes
indeed and chitty chess or I talked
about doing Shakespeare when I was uh
that was how I got my uh start in the
United States doing Shakespeare and we
compared notes on that she did say this
we love to go to the theater I'm not
going to do an imitation of the queen
under that you cut it you got it
she said she said we love going to the
theater and my sister
my sister could go to the theater and
hear a song once and then come home
and I said
played on the piano and she said yes
I helmet with her majesty who used to
call her majesty first and then you call
ma'am we've met the queen I have yes and
here you are getting uh is it MB you got
I got the NBA does she knows
anything about Formula One she actually
did when she was talking to me there and
she said we watch you but the best thing
is I got invited back
um like a year later for lunch you made
an impression with a group that was
about it was about eight of us and we I
turned up after the Brazilian Grand Prix
came back and um walked in saw the the
seating plan and I was sat right next to
her she spoke to the guy next to her for
like five five minutes and then she
spent the rest of time talking to me yes
you wanted it was really really cool
shut off bake off you know it opened all
these doors to you and all sorts of
honors and things and uh but one of the
biggest Thrills must have been when you
got to bake the the Queen's birthday
cake yeah there you are she's the one
the one that I met that made me the most
nervous In fairness yeah
as this is the daughter that made the
cake for the queen I don't even have a
name anymore
but I didn't know Prince Philip was
there so he saunters around I'm trying
to talk muffling all my words and then
he comes up and he said and the queen
then introduced me to Prince Philip I
was like get in you know you made it
when she introduces you to somebody else
and they said this this is the young
lady who who won the baking competition
and I was at this point I was Cloud Nine
and he comes up yesterday I know who she
is but what flavor's the cake
since we last saw you on the show as
much as I would hoopla hurray uh you've
got your Obe from the queen
thank you
about 12. oh it must be it must have
been amazing she thought she was giving
it to Tony Blair
Jean did that come up well uh she did
she did say to me because she and this
is so extraordinary thing we drove into
Buckingham Palace I went with my well
there's you with the other with the with
the other Queen the fake queen yeah yeah
uh we drove in there and it was
strangely like deja vu because we'd
recreated it for the film The Queen so I
sort of felt quite at home there
and then you get in front of the actual
Queen and uh and there's all these rules
that you have you know the etiquette and
stuff you have to go in you must never
turn your back on the queen and all this
kind of stuff so I turn up and and she
sort of and she's got someone next to
her going this is Michael Sheen he's a
Herbert from Wales
uh he played in that film about you and
you come up and she comes forward and
she shakes her hand and uh and then she
and then she sort of puts the medal on
you and then she said um
she said so what are you doing next and
uh when I told my agent in America that
she went oh Everyone's an agent
and I thought the truth was that I was
about to do a film called Tron
uh but I thought that probably wouldn't
go down well with the queen she might
not get that and I've only got a short
amount of time to talk to her so I said
I'm doing another film about
uh ex-prime Minister Blair and this
one's about uh his relationship with
President Bill Clinton
and she got a little sort of Sparkle in
her eye and she went oh
that must be awfully difficult
I've lived most people I've wanted to
meet the queen well it was a yeah when I
was when I was uh quite young I saw I
Saw The Royal Variety Show and the
comedian that was on had met the queen
so I assume that that meant you must be
really funny to meet the queen you have
to be like she she says he's funny
enough to meet me I thought that's how
it worked it command you to be funny yes
in the Royal Command Performance they
literally command you you know then
finally this year and it generally was
true that at the end of the book I was
trying to think of a way of ending the
book
um and I'd mentioned wanting to meet the
queen in the book and literature as I
was trying to finish it I got a phone
call to ask if I could do the Jubilee
concert this year and and host it and I
thought this would be great I get to
meet the queen and there was so much
pressure everyone I mean we're all
nervous about doing the gig but I was
more nervous about ending my book so I
had to meet the queen
to get the photo
and so that she come and they chucked
her out everybody that wasn't it was
such a small room so the person who's
going to take the photograph couldn't
take it so she said I've been thrown out
it's just you lot that were in the show
so she hands me the camera and I see
Alfie Bo the opera singer and I go Alfie
mate don't mess this up there's the
camera make sure that when she you've
got to get this shot
yeah I think if you have a look at the
shot
it's not exactly what you call
I'll tell you what
I was going to re-change the whole story
I didn't want to meet the queen I always
wanted to meet Kylie Minogue and Lenny
Henry
[Music]
bless him he didn't I didn't give him
much warn I said press that button and
just hope for the best and he did and
did she talk to you or you just met her
she was great actually she was really
she she did this thing with Gary Barlow
and Kylie it was her job to show around
everybody and I think Carl didn't know
who I was and panicked and just backed
off because she didn't want to introduce
me and uh so the queen was less stranded
on her own
um we were making polite conversation
around I saw the queen look around as if
to go usually I'm dragged away at this
point but no one's coming together
honestly you were very close to Prince
Diana but even before that you uh I
think you played at winter castle Yeah
yeah
um and that was a very nervous
experience because Ray Cooper and my
percussion player and myself played and
suddenly you looked in the balcony and
these are all gold chairs and suddenly
they fill up and you think oh God and we
played and I came down I changed and I
was in a ballroom with a band and Diana
Spencer she wasn't Prince Charles's wife
then and she said do you want to dance
so I can't dance anywhere but we did as
faux Charleston and then we went into
dinner and then it was a buffet dinner
and then Princess Anne said should we go
to the Disco and I said it's as quiet as
disco you've ever heard
to dance with Princess Anthony you know
what I was born in a counselor she's
very surreal and then the queen came in
and she said can we join you and I said
say no [__] off right
and they segued into rock around the
clock by Bill Haley and I thought this
is ridiculous because the Queen's going
like
and it was one of the most that to that
point surreal moments of my life because
you know it after being born in a
council house in Pinner and you think
I'm remembering Brock Around the Clock
by well Haley you would the odds of you
dancing with the queen at Windsor Castle
back
[Music]
we came to the set of Game of Thrones
the queen yes
in your face
yeah we've got a picture over there she
is so they kept trying to push her to
sit down on the throne and we kept
getting told the same thing which is
she's not allowed to sit on other
Thrones fictional or otherwise
there's a thing for that yeah but I'm
afraid did you talk to her I did yes
yeah and she was delightful but what did
you talk about what not much she asked
me a question and I said yes ma'am and
then she moved on
and what do you do on this production
you said yes and I said I said yes
and she said oh wonderful and moved on
and then they asked if she won a certain
Throne she said looks very uncomfortable
[Music]